égide
dans l'est
oui non c'est pas demain la carie
les
[Musique]
à temps
longtemps dans ce sens là
avec ce que la dame avec le masque bleu
indique corinne parce que le serpent
toute la région
axb
ouais les grilles et tout
m
qu'est ce que les charges
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous merci de nous suit en
direct sur figaro live via lefigaro.fr
et notre chaîne youtube nous allons
vivre ensemble ce matin les obsèques de
jean paul belmondo qui a eu hier les
honneurs d'un hommage national en
présence du président de la république
emmanuel macron aux invalides on a
encore en tête un bertrand guyard et
vous me démentirait pas sujet l'image
magnifique du cercueil de la de l'acteur
quittant la cour de l'hôtel des
invalides sur la musique du
professionnel jouer pour l'occasion par
la garde républicaine et le choeur des
armes et beaucoup d'émotion donc pour
cette cérémonie hier et une émotion
encore présentes ce matin de nouveau
avec donc les obsèques de l'acteur qui
devrait débuter à 11h en l'église saint
germain des prés vous le voyez en ce
moment sur les images que nous vous
proposons les arrivées déjà deux des
invités on voit sur ces images le
comédien pierre richard qui arrive à
l'instant derrière le corbillard est
arrivé il y a une dizaine de minutes
maintenant c'est le corbillard avec la
dépouille 1 2
jean paul belmondo qui sera la dernière
à entrer dans cette église à 11 heures
en attendant quelques invités se
pressent pour entrer dans cette église
on annonce des obsèques dans l'intimité
réservée à la famille et aux proches de
jean paul belmondo
une cérémonie dans un cadre on va dire
plus simple bertrand guyard et prise en
accord probablement avec l'image de
l'homme et l'homme qui était jean paul
belmondo je crois que belmondo 200
vivant était humble et en même temps il
était toujours
à l'écouté de son public il était moi je
l' ai croisé deux fois dans ma vie et il
était déjà il était déjà il avait déjà
un certain âge il marchait avec sa canne
il était droit dès qu'ils avaient du
public ici souriait il savait que
c'était son rôle de saltimbanques donc
je pense que lille son fils a fait une
très belle déclaration en disant que
finalement son père aurait aurait
apprécié et aurait certainement apprécié
tous ces hommages
là on voit qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de monde sur la place saint germain des
prés derrière les grilles je pense que
oui il faut ça il faut que ça
corresponde à ce qu'il était c'est à
quelqu'un qui était humble qui savez
savez ce qu'avait dit rochefort c'était
jean rochefort son grand copain et david
heath était un superman sans être
conscients qu'ils étaient super man donc
ils étaient les deux en même temps c'est
à dire au service de son métier au
service donc du public pour lui c'était
pour selon lui a beaucoup reproché
d'avoir fait des belles monde rit mais
c'était pour distraire le public et en
même temps je crois qu'il était aussi
conscient quand même un peu de l'image
qu'il avait dans le public et puis
c'était un donc je crois qu'il faut il
faut que ça faut que tout ça ne lui
correspond donc l'église de
saint-germain-des-prés elle est au
milieu du coeur dirait intellectuelle de
ce1 de paris oui faisait ou belmondo
faisait des blagues il racontait jean
paul sartre ça quand il était jeune il a
d'ailleurs piqué l'est parce que vous
savez on était encore le lait voilà
donc c'est certain et puis bedeau son
copain était aussi aussi la messe s'est
passé là donc c'est je pense que j'ai on
va voir comment ça va se passer mais je
pense que ça va être en même temps
chaleureux à l'image encore une fois de
belmondo si vous venez de nous rejoindre
en direct sur figaro live nous vous
faisons vivre les obsèques du comédien
de l'acteur du grand acteur jean paul
belmondo qui doivent débuter à 11h en
l'église saint-germain-des-prés à paris
pour l'instant nous assistons à
l'arrivée des invités à la famille et
les proches de jean paul belmondo on a
pu voir arriver pierre richard entre
autres d'autres sont attendus évidemment
proche d'eux l'acteur on attend alain
delon également claude lelouch serait là
il n'était pas présent hier
contrairement à ce qu'on vous a annoncé
il serait là aujourd'hui
thibault il aurait notre envoyé spécial
sur place présents sur place devant
cette église de saint germain des prés
je ne sais pas si vous m'entendez
thibault le public s'est-il pressés en
nombre ce matin devant l'église saint
germain des prés de nouveau pour pour
dire au revoir à jean paul belmondo
bonjour charlotte bonjour à tous merci
de nous rejoindre aujourd'hui dans une
nouvelle journée d'hommage à l'occasion
de ses obsèques qui se déroule derrière
moi à l'église saint germain des prés en
effet charlotte est bien de nouveau
commis hier des français sont venus se
rassembler tout haut de l'église alors
depuis tout à l'heure on peut entendre
des applaudissements à l'arrivée
notamment de pierre richard comme vous
l'avez rappelé alors juste une petite
parenthèse mais pour vous montrer un
petit peu l'ambiance ici assez populaire
c'est simple et c'est que l'acteur jean
dujardin se trouve dans le café jusqu'à
herman on peut malheureusement pas les
l'embêter pendant qu'il prend son café
mais comme vous le voyez finalement
l'ambiance reste extrêmement populaire
avec est bien également beaucoup des
fusions au niveau des photographes et
des journalistes aux différentes
arrivées des personnalités qui sont
venus assister dans l'intimité à cette
cérémonie d'obsèques pour l'acteur jean
paul belmondo est justement mais je vous
propose de partir à la rencontre d'une
des françaises qui est venu rendre
hommage à l'acteur
voulait pas parler finalement
mais juste en fait ci ou comme on disait
tout à l'heure si vous voyez m'expliquer
ce que la raison
il ya passé vous pourriez juste me dire
en quelques mots l'importance pour vous
d'être ici aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et je zoome expliqué que vous pouviez
pas être ici hier pour les invalides
mais qu'en revanche vous aviez prévu
peut-être d'aller à son domicile
vraiment lui rendre hommage en mettant
avec les bâtiments pressafrik com je
suis quelqu'un de sensible
ironique je peux pas exprimer vraiment
ce que je ressens je comprends tout à
fait beaucoup d'émotion pour aujourd'hui
dans sept jours il n'y a pas de soucis
qu à part
ça il n'y a pas de souci par pétain
merci beaucoup de votre de votre
témoignage en tout cas et donc vous le
voyez et bien beaucoup d'émotion dans
les yeux de cette française qui avec qui
on discute et tout à l'heure qui me
disait qu'elle était finalement capable
de parler et là vous voyez l'émotion qui
monte d'un coup à la proche vient du
début de cette cérémonie est donc bien
beaucoup de deux français pour tout vous
dire d'ailleurs finalement l'ambiance
c'est un petit peu et bien et
intensifier au passage justement de
cette approche et vous voyez les gens
qui est bien ce plus le long des
barrières pour justement et bien appelé
les différentes personnalités qui
arrivent et qui accède vous le voyez au
dessus des photographes à l'entrée de
cette église saint-germain-des-prés
merci beaucoup ou thibault il aurait on
l'a vu un le public est très émue cette
femme était très touché visiblement et
ne voulant plus s'exprimer en direct
auprès de notre journaliste cette
émotion
ressentie par part par les français on
l'avait déjà constaté hier bertrand
guyard alors qu'on voit à l'image
monsieur frémont je crois qui est le
patron du festival de cannes
grand connaisseur évidemment de jean
paul belmondo je reviens juste sur sur
l'émotion suscitée par le décès de jean
paul belmondo jean paul belmondo qui
avait une proximité extraordinaire avec
les français qui disait de lui même la
france c'est moi
daniel mccraw hier lors de son éloge
funèbre l'a de nouveau mis en avant nous
aimons jean paul belmondo parce qu'il
nous ressembler il fut l'ami que chacun
rêvé d'avoir
c'est ça en fait jean paul belmondo
c'est ça qui fait craquer les français
aujourd'hui qui endeuillent tout un pays
c'était sa proximité avec nous oui alors
peut-être à la fin de sa vie parce que
c'est vrai que c'était fassiez dans
paris quand on était parisien en tout
cas de de le croiser dans les
restaurants que c'était quelque chose
d'assez étonnant mais surtout vous dire
les choses il a joué des rôles de héros
je suis en six places des assassins
qu'est-ce qu'il joue il joue un un
boxeur déjà quelque chose un entraîneur
de boxe et
il va casser la gueule il a cassé la
gueule aux allemands et va casser la
gueule aux nazis il est le héros
français donc il y incarne et puis
encore une fois est un héros qui se
prenait pas trop au sérieux et puis
quand même et puis et puis alors après
quand on est le plus cinéphile on se
rend compte qu'il a joué avec on avec
les plus grands acteurs de ce aux
actrices de son temps sophia loren gina
lollobrigida claudia cardinale en italie
il a joué il a été le héros mais avait
h&r à ut de la nouvelle vague oui donc
c'était une carrière exceptionnelle et
puis c'était le oui c'est quand même à
box au box office on dit que 230
millions d'eu j'ai pas comment ils ont
calculé ça peu importe mais enfin en
tout cas c'était quand même long on
attendait le belmondo dans les années
70-80 comme on attendait un peu avant le
de funès comme on a attendu quand même
un peu le de long 1 il y avait quand
même quelques belles motos d'ailleurs
c'était son
d'un film aujourd'hui on se rend compte
que d'être avec
d'excellents réalisateur de ré lautner
verneuil évidemment etc etc mais c'est
vrai que au fond à l'affût dans les
années 70 85 ils pariaient sur la marque
belmondo et et après effectivement une
fois qu'il a eu son avc ce qui est son
avc avant 70 ans je crois qu il avait 69
ans il a montré un courage fou c'est
quelqu'un qui ne s'est jamais plaint
l'arrivée de claude lelouch en ce moment
en direct à l'image claude lelouch le
réalisateur qui a fait tourner jean paul
belmondo dans itinéraire d'un enfant
gâté dont on attendait la présence hier
mais en fait il était retenu au festival
de deauville il est là ce matin parmi
les proches de l'acteur dans cette
église de saint germain des prés où doit
se dérouler à 11 heures les obsèques
doivent se dérouler les obsèques du
comédien jean paul belmondo vous le
voyez claude lelouch qui répond aux
journalistes de nos confrères des
télévisions françaises il l'a fait jouer
trois fois donc itinéraire d'un enfant
gâté je les cite est donc ça c'est son
césar que ben elle n'a pas récupéré
quand même on peut expliquer après
pourquoi mai
et avant dans un homme qui me plaît avec
annie girardot ou là où aussi le faisait
jouer dans un peu dans un contre emploi
je recommande qui est peu connu va à nos
internautes c'est un film splendide
excessivement émouvant avec une annie
girardot magnifique magnifique la scène
finale en particulier à vos charlotte il
a joué aussi un rôle dans les misérables
où il jouait un jean valjean a là aussi
à jean valjean jean valjean évidemment
c'est le héros des misérables idasa a
été jouée par harry baur d'un flash au
début du 20e siècle et puis après par
gabin puis après par lino puis après par
et puis aussi les grands acteurs
américains
l'ont joué donc oui des grands acteurs
jouent les rôles aussi les personnages
mythiques
vous nous rejoignez en ce moment sur
figaro live le figaro.fr youtube nous
sommes en direct pour vous faire vivre
les obsèques de jean paul belmondo en
tout cas l'arrivée des invités de la
famille et à ses obsèques qui doivent
débuter en l'église de saint germain des
prés à 11 heures
il est déjà très nombreux à nous faire
part de votre émotion de nouveau comme
il hier lors de l'hommage national on en
parlait de cette émotion nous trailer
nous avons obtenu le témoignage d'une
femme présente dans la foule devant
cette église et qui avait du mal à
exprimer ce qu'elle ressentait et bien
c'est pareil sur youtube par exemple
vous avez sandrine garcia de nouveau
toutes mes condoléances pour ce grand
monsieur belmondo que j'ai connu il ya
25 ans c'était un homme très gentil très
généreux adieu monsieur belmondo dit
elle target ajoute à dieu jean-paul
brigitte bucari bébel on t'aime tu
resteras tu tu resteras toujours dans
nos coeurs vicat nous dit sincères
condoléances à sa famille à ses proches
il va nous manquer je suis en pleurs
depuis que j'ai appris son décès il
aurait pu être mon grand père nous avons
vu depuis quelques minutes arriver là
nous voyons je prends francis huster le
comédien francis huster qui est là
également le fait tourner son dernier
film ah oui non mais sont un homme et
son chien absolument en 2008 si je me
trouvais ça
aux côtés de nous sur la pas citer mon a
vu paraître furtivement béatrice dalle
également qui était présente dans la
même voiture elle même convoi que claude
lelouch francis huster qui effectivement
a fait tourner jean paul belmondo
dans le dernier film de jean paul
belmondo pardon continuez à nous faire
part de vos commentaires de votre
émotion de vos témoignages vos films
préférés de jean paul belmondo ce sont
ses obsèques et aujourd'hui il hier
c'était l'hommage national
je vous demandais hier bertrand guyard
quelle était votre film préféré
il ya peut-être des films qu'on pourrait
recommander de jean paul belmondo à aux
internautes qui nous regardent un peu
méconnu comme c'est mon site est il ya
quelques minutes alors oui à d'abord il
ya des films de jeunesse elle est comme
les copains du dimanche c'est un film
qui a été financée par le parti
communiste vous il ya des films les
distractions un petit film là je parle
des films qui sont pas connues moi même
je connaissais pas ou peu que j'ai vu
après avec claude brasseur est en jeunes
hier soir par exemple j'ai revu un
week-end à lui à celui de côte de
d'henri verneuil ça c'est un excellent
film parce que c'est belmondo j'irai
avant belmondo est ce que on l'a déjà
dit il ya plusieurs périodes il ya une
période au fond il n'est pas le super
héros il ya celui qui crée le
super-héros belmondo c'est c'est
philippe de broca dans l'homme de rio
vous l'a effectivement c'est déjà on est
déjà 63 64 ça fait trois ans qu'il est
célèbre qui croient à l'avenir je vous
interromps côté alain delon qui arrive
alors si je me trompe pas alors il a
joué dans soit belle et tais toi et qui
a vidé avec de longs et que mylène
demongeot qui était la star du film si
c'était très jeune après ils ont rejoué
un autre film je veux pas dire de
bêtises parce que je veux faire encorner
je crois qu'il rejoue dans l'est
peut-être des petits rôles dans les
tricheurs peut-être des deux ils ont ils
ont joué dans paris brûle-t-il où ils
ont des de l'eau douce chaban delmas et
et
belmondo un autre un autre résistant
important
assez dupontel convoi non c'est dû
planter à louer et
ils ont joué surtout dans borsalino vous
lassez sont les deux les deux les deux
hyper vedettes du cinéma français qui
vont être amis qui vont s'affronter
belmondo meurt dans les bras de long en
disant tu vois rock la chance n'existe
pas feinte outillés et donc oui ils
étaient rivaux mais
évident évidemment alors là donc alors
je crois que sur les images qu'on
diffuse en ce moment je crois que c'est
bien alain delon qui devrait sortir de
ce véhicule
il fait partie donc des proches invité
avec la famille ce matin pour assister
aux obsèques de destin de jean paul
belmondo qui ont lieu donc je vous le
disais en l'église de
saint-germain-des-prés au coeur de paris
le destin terrible quand même quand on
voit que c'est calme lui aussi qui a
subi un avc voyez où c'est terrible
parce qu'il y avait il est il avait
pleuré en deçà 10 ou 15 ans à l'antenne
en voyant en voyant là
l état de santé de son copain lui aussi
rattrapé par l'âge tout simplement on va
laisser vivre ces images si on peut
avoir le son je crois qu'il est très
applaudie alain delon par le public qui
s'est massée devant les grilles pour
fédérer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans le masquer
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
c'est dur
[Musique]
bien d'armures à la violence
c'est devant le mas et de montceau lès
metz
[Applaudissements]
dans après publics ont-ils dit
des règles publiques de belmondo s'était
aussi d'une certaine façon celui de
nantes sont associés l'un à l'autre pour
l'éternité oui j'ai apprécié de les deux
acteurs
pour des raisons différentes il y avait
une rivalité mais je pense que je pense
que les deux un carnet de un carnet de
deux formes de rôles évidemment c'était
toujours lui son rôle chez le samouraï
c'est un rôle de solitaire alors que les
grands rôles de bébelles sont toujours
des rôles de deux grands copains de
grand frère bons
mais ils ont travaillé l'été avec les
mêmes bases d'un travail et il devrait
le
trouver des grands films certains grands
films de belmondo c'est à l'île de ré
élu il a fait la piscine allemand
évidemment ils ont travaillé aussi pour
être un peu plus cinéphiles ont
travaillé aussi dans une période
italienne parce que dans les années 60
le grand cinéma était était en italie
permettez moi un commentaire personnel
mais un peu un familier mais il en
assure encore
je pense je pense que c'est toujours
impressionnant je ne sais pas si je vais
raconter ça tout seul et moi j'ai croisé
j'ai croisé simplement de deux fois
belmondo dans ma vie et d'élise et et
c'est quand il était face au public donc
c'était dans des réunions publiques face
au public qui se tenait droit il était
déjà très handicapée à l'époque mais je
pense que ce sont des saltimbanques ce
sont des ce sont des clowns ce sont des
gens qui est qui qui travaille pour le
public pour divertir le public soit en
les faisant pleurer soit en les faisant
rire
mais évidemment ils ont besoin de ça
on a deux noms qui y restent sur le
parvis de cette église de saint germain
des prés qui profite de la présence du
public également on imagine à quel point
les motions fragilise même un être comme
alain delon dans un événement comme
celui-ci et le public et est là pour
soutenir on va dire ces personnalités
oui je pense que pour le public de
public qui pense exactement comme
c'était qu'ils savent intuitivement que
les deux cas ya son fils anthony qui
vient d'arriver anthony delon en finisse
et
ils savent que les deux hommes se sont
liés encore une fois il ya eu il ya une
petite vis bio moment de borsalino parce
que delon avait mis deux fois son cv
l'histoire est connue avait mis deux
fois son nom sur la fiche parce qu'il
était évidemment premier acteur avec le
moment donné il était producteur elle
même ça ça n'avait pas plu à ça n'avait
pas plu à bordeaux qui lui je répète a
quand même toujours défendu becs bec et
ongles les droits d
des acteurs et qui n'a jamais voulu lui
passer derrière la caméra il a acheté il
avait acheté un théâtre mai
il était directeur de théâtre il a été
acteur il était producteur un peu mais
jamais jamais mettant en scène
alain delon et son fils anthony delon
qui se sont arrêtés
quelques minutes pour faire le pas sur
le parvis pour pour faire quelques
quelques clichés avec les photographes
et les télévisions présentes sur place
et qui vont donc entrer dans cette
église de saint germain des prés où doit
débuter
la messe
dédiée à jean paul belmondo ce sont ses
obsèques que comme vous fait vivre en ce
moment en direct sur figaro l'arrivée
sur youtube vous n'hésitez pas à nous
faire part de vos commentaires si vous
avez des questions également
nous pouvons vous répondre grâce à
l'expertisé de notre invité aujourd'hui
bertrand guyard spécialiste de jean paul
belmondo du service culture du figaro
je vous cite et encore vous les
internautes qui nous suivait
clémentine chaix bonjour monsieur alain
delon anciens de l'indochine comme fut
mon défunt père de la même génération
que vous jouez le brave nous dit de long
est au rendez vous pour son copain
respect à lui
merci beaucoup à faux figaro pour les
images en direct
merci à vous arnaud yves éthique de nous
faire part de votre satisfaction merci
delon j'imagine sa peine qui doit être
immensément grand nous dit jérémy
cheuvreux
alors que les invités famille proche de
jean paul belmondo sont toujours
attendus en cette église de saint
germain d'être prêt on le voit la foule
est assez tempête assez importante ce
matin devant cette église alors que déjà
hier pour l'hommage national c'était les
pelouses des invalides qui était
accessible avec des écrans géants pour
retransmettre l'hommage national aux
français françaises désireuses
d'assister à cet événement exceptionnel
et puis 1000 personnes on vous le
rappelle avait pu entrer dans ces
invalides pour assister à cet hommage
qui a été rendu par le chef de l'état
hier on a pu entendre victor belmondo le
petit fils de jean paul belmondo
dans un discours émouvant
le président de la république a fait
l'éloge funèbre de jean paul belmondo et
puis je vous le disais au début de cette
émission on garde en mémoire ces images
sublimes et cette émotion forte au
départ du cercueil sur la musique
interprétée par la garde républicaine du
professionnel d'ennio morricone
ça signe un film de terriblement et on a
été pris par l'émotion et je pense
beaucoup de gens aussi parce que parce
qu en pleurs alors en plus dans le
professionnel himeur à la fin du film
la musique du professionnel qui devrait
selon les informations que nous avons
être rejoué à la demande de jean paul
belmondo dans cette église de saint
germain des prés pendant cette cérémonie
qui doit débuter à
11hoo on voit sur ces images
toujours quelques invités qui sont
déposés devant l'église
du lait antoine duléry formidable
comédien et proche de jean paul belmondo
était très proche les dernières années
quand j'ai quand j'étais allé voir
depardieu qui chantait barbara
belmondo était à l'écouté aussi et
duléry était à côté de
belmondo ils ont joué ensemble
ils ont joué ensemble je crois au
théâtre je rêve ce serait plus ils sont
connus comme ça oui
à brahim asloum le boxeur qui arrivent
également alors oui ça c'est toute la
légende de la boxe et toutes les
légendes de belmondo ida faut le
rappeler de la moto était un vrai boxeur
il était boxeur amateur il a tout de
même des afin d'aider vrai combat
à la vie à club c'est là où il rencontre
son fameux copain charles gérard et puis
il a été très très amis alors avec il
allait voir tous les grands combats là
jusqu'à récemment mais il était très ami
avec maurice aux ailes qui avait été
champion de france dans sa catégorie je
me suis plus là qu'elle est
maurice aux elle a dû faire au moins dix
ou quinze films avec bell dont l'aîné
des ferchaux c'est à dire l'adaptation
du roman de
simenon
wilf et où le combat il combat on le
voit on les voit combattre à l'écran
belmondo et sa gueule de boxer un
c'était un peu le beau gosse pas beau du
cinéma physique absolument inhabituel 1
quand il a déboulé comme ça dans le pas
dans le paysage cinématographique
français il changé les codes
radicalement voilà c'est pas fait il est
lui-même le raconter s'est pas fait
casser son nez et s'est fait casser son
nez je crois à l'école dans une bagarre
de récréation mais
il avait oui ce qu'on appelle une gueule
une gueule de cinéma
c'est à dire qu'il avait pas la beauté
d'un des alpes à la beauté d'un gregory
peck même d'un alain delon d'un gary
cooper ce n'était pas une beauté
classique mais soit ils étaient quand
même grand costaud il avait des yeux
clairs
et puis il avait cette énergie
incroyable qui lui a fait faire entre
autres des cascades qui resteront qui
resteront dans l'histoire du cinéma
si vous nous rejoignez en direct en ce
moment sur figaro live et youtube nous
vous faisons vivre les obsèques de jean
paul belmondo ou belmondo qui ont lieu
en ce moment et qui vont débuter dans
quelques minutes maintenant l'église
saint-germain-des-prés à paris nous vous
montrons l'arrivée des invités une
cérémonie intime réservée à la famille
de jean paul belmondo et aux proches de
jean paul belmondo on a pu voir arriver
parmi les personnalités du monde du
cinéma pierre richard
brahim asloum du monde de la boxe on a
vu claude lelouch qui n'était pas
présent hier à l'hommage national mais
qui est présent aujourd'hui et puis
évidemment alain delon très attendu et
qui est arrivé il ya quelques minutes
maintenant et qui restait assez
longtemps sur le parvis de l'église de
saint-germain-des-prés qui a retiré son
masque il a été très applaudi par la
foule son fils anthony l'a rejoint pour
poser devant les caméras et les
photographes
on a vu également parmi les
personnalités
de
mais
je me souviens plus pierre richard jeu
les cités j'ai un petit des petites
absences excusées mois on en les re
citera total pour dupontel c'est albert
dupontel dont je cherchais le nom le
réalisateur merci bernard murat
également qui a salué alain delon
vous êtes encore nombreux à nous faire
part de votre émotion sur sur internet
sur les réseaux sociaux du figaro je
pense qu'on peut aller de nouveau
retrouver un autre envoyé spécial
thibault il aurait sur place qui est au
milieu de la foule très présentes ce
matin pour ses obsèques de jean paul
belmondo peut-être peut-il nous faire un
petit point de ce qui se passe est
peut-être at-il le témoignage d'un
français ou une française sur place qui
s'est déplacé pour assister à cet
événement
thibault si vous entendez thibault vous
pouvez intervenir pour nous dire ce
qu'il se passe sur place en ce moment
oui charlotte excusez-moi intercup est
très mauvaise je vous entends très mal
mais en effet bien ici vous pouvez le
voir la situation est toujours très vive
avec bien beaucoup beaucoup
d'interactions notamment vous avez vu
vous l'autre côté des images avec
l'arrivée notamment d'alain delon qui a
été extrêmement remarqué mais est bien
ici du côté du public et bien beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotion notamment au passage
de cet acteur immense qui aux côtés de
jean paul belmondo est évidemment très
fort dans l'émotion de ces personnes
rassemblées ici notamment des
photographes qui pour le coup n'avait là
avec une photo importante à prendre avec
l'arrivée de cet acteur et vous voyez
derrière moi je vais vous montrer les
images et et cette ambiance avec le son
si vous pouvez le l'accroître un peu
et voilà vous le voyez c'est donc bien
un petit peu ces scènes que l'on vit
depuis tout à l'heure avec et bien
beaucoup d'applaudissements lors de
l'arrivée de certains acteurs et de
certaines personnalités de la société
française pour bien ses obsèques dans
l'intimité du côté de l'église du saint
germain des prés
merci beaucoup ou thibault il aurait
notre envoyé spécial sur place devant
cette église de saint germain des prés
où doit avoir lieu dans quelques minutes
maintenant les obsèques de jean paul
belmondo une foule rassemblée en nombre
on l'a vu avec beaucoup d'émotion auprès
des françaises et français qui ont venus
dire un dernier au revoir à jean paul
belmondo alors que se présente quelques
je crois que c'est jacques dutronc le
chanteur qui arrive
c'est vrai qu'avec les masques on
identifie pas du tout ces pages elle
dutronc
on identifie pas très bien pardon en
tout cas un certain nombre de
personnalités qui font partie des
proches de jean paul belmondo sont déjà
installés en cette église de saint
germain des prés on a pu voir entre
autres alain delon rester un certain
temps sur ce parvis pour faire plaisir à
la foule et au public massé devant cette
église il l'a posé avec son fils anthony
delon on a pu voir pierre richard aussi
entrer dans l'église béatrice dalle
claude lelouch
voilà pour dire un dernier au revoir à
l'acteur français dont on a beaucoup
parlé depuis lundi lundi nous avons
appris son décès un acteur est mort à 88
ans jean dujardin à la terrasse des deux
magots qui avant d'entrer dans un café
on est vigilants derrière on l'a raté on
l'a pas vu entrer dans l'église mais
jean dujardin il a de nouveau
aujourd'hui il était présent à l'hommage
national hier
on va regarder ce qui se passe
maintenant ils essaient vivent ces
images puisque ça va être l'entrée du
cercueil de jean-paul belmondo dans
l'église
si on peut monter le son en régie pour
avoir le sont sur place et de son
ambiance merci
[Applaudissements]
enfin
et sa fille stella ainsi que paul
belmondo son fils
il devrait débuter dans quelques minutes
maintenant place à la musique
avant des prêts
politique
on freine
finalement ils sont pas les seuls à le
re et donc ils partagent quand même leur
peine avec tout parce que
aux acteurs appartient à tout le monde
alors c'est difficile pour les enfants
comme vous dites de partager un son père
ou sa mère
alors évidemment avec un pays entier on
pense à stella qui est qui est une
enfant puisque le le fils aîné de
favorite il a vu il a perdu une fille
aussi belle mango patricia morte
tragiquement dans un accident domestique
mais là l'aîné de ses enfants c'est paul
qui a 58 ans est donc la plus jeune la
plus jeune a 18 qui effectivement de la
génération de ses petits-enfants
je pense que c'était je pense que
c'était une famille unie en plus il
était certainement très proche deux de
ses neveux d'aider des enfants de dallas
belmondo avec qui ils ont toujours été
très très bientôt
juste je parlais des dés de ses sorties
au restaurant quotidienne il y avait
toujours cher djerra il y avait souvent
très très souvent alain belmondo dont
ils ont été lui c'était c'était était
plutôt quelqu'un qui était derrière la
caméra mais c'est lui qui s'est occupé
il a créé entre autres il avait créé une
société de production qui s'appelle
cerrito du nom de la grand mère
sicilienne de de belmondo
et c'est lui qui s'occupait de saré
les portes de l'église de
saint-germain-des-prés se sont refermées
après l'entrée du cercueil de jean-paul
belmondo suivi par
une partie de sa famille en l'occurrence
ses enfants ses petits-enfants on a pu
voir paul belmondo stella belmondo sa
dernière fille
vous êtes encore nombreux à nous faire
part de vos sentiments de votre émotion
sur les réseaux sociaux du figaro michel
now nous dit bébel c'est le sourire
de s'agit maintenant de sa génération
qui nous le transmet on ne retrouvera
pas d'autres sourires comme celui de
bébelles bébel tu nous manques tiens à
propos de bébelles justement ce surnom
bébel comment il n' est l'hymne est ce
personnage des modèles c'était de
raconter lui même s'était pepel et
c'était un nom qui a été donné au début
de sa carrière 1 c'était ans en
référence à un autre acteur appel bébel
on sait diminutif de belmondo assez
simple alors mais le mont dol l'aimé
bien mais c'est vrai qu'on était il ya
deux choses dit à jean paul belmondo
c'est le grand acteur et bébel c'est le
sait le héros bondissant de des films
d'action on peut on pourrait simplifier
ça comme ça on va retrouver thibault il
aurait sur place notre envoyé spécial
est et dans la foule parmi les français
et françaises qui ont tenu à dire au
revoir à jean paul belmondo ce matin au
coeur de paris face à cette église de
saint germain des prés où se déroule en
ce moment même les obsèques du comédien
tribune thibault il aurait c'est à vous
vous êtes je crois avec un fan de jean
paul belmondo
je suis un peu sourd je suis désolé je
ne vous entends pas du tout en revanche
et bien voilà vous l'avez vu l'entrée du
cercueil dans cette église
saint-germain-des-prés et bien du côté
ici de l'hommage de ces français qui
sont venus se rassembler une dernière
fois pour les obsèques de jean paul
belmondo je vous propose d'aller à la
rencontre d'eric eric bonjour merci de
ne parler je crois savoir que vous étiez
déjà présents hier aux invalides
pourquoi c'était important pour vous
d'être présents hier et aujourd'hui
pourquoi c'était important je suis
arrivé de province avant-hier
estivale
c'est
jean paul belmondo fait partie
et rares à ses acteurs
mondiaux
pour lequel n'a pas pu l'arrêter
et l'amour de l'amour qu'il avait pour
son côté
rejoint
nous notre carrière
jean paul bulcke
j'ai rencontré énormément lecteurs parce
que j'ai pas mais dans un an j'ai eu
l'occasion de
de le croiser
où sont tous les terrains
2001 expulsion trouvé en suggérant comme
avocat sur l'aîné des ferchaux de
bernard stora qui était le remake du
film
une ville et puis
en 2000
insecticide en occident et après on
assister en direct à une cascade qui a
duré vingt
exor du projet en 2008 j'ai réussi à
faire le dernier joueur de son âge de
france austère il ya eu le droit à une
standing ovation il nous a reçu dans son
camion là j'avais que gianni coup d'état
et ses compagnons d'armes jean paul
était comme chez eux
jean-paul parler du jeu avec lui à la
gaillette
régulièrement la
camerise ionita pour rendre hommage dans
cette dernière on l'a vu en
à diverses reprises joubert présente
mais avant de vous des derniers avec un
push et pis pour les cinq comme ça comme
un singe en hiver avec ce nouveau style
brass qui étaient aux américains alors
beaucoup d'émotion pour vous j'imagine
comment vous avez ressenti la cérémonie
pierre ce passage aujourd'hui du
cercueil et ses amis à la roche mois
déjà
sur neuf une
l'appartenance politique je trouve que
les azéris c'est un livre dédié sur aux
militaires et tout ça mais je trouve
normal que dans des cas extrêmes
accident mission
ils y ont droit que cet homme là parce
qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup d'équivalent
je vous parle de comparer c'est vrai
qu'il réunit la simple il réunit
d'humour le gigabit et la force du jeu
de
l'évasion
le côté cascade d'ars et voilà
il les a rejoint
il ya aux aveux tous ces grands qui
s'étend acteurs français qu'eux-mêmes
des américains
que du mal à rivaliser d'ailleurs je
vois un peu ce que de d'acteur il une
carrière aussi longue aux états unis il
ya du steward douglas est pleinement de
ces états c'est un monument d'humanité
aussi de générosité
qu'il était
ils étaient ils étaient ministère
nationale et même mondiale il a refusé
d'ailleurs
de tournage et américains ce qui nous
arrive anglais malgré le fait qu'il est
une passion et une en baisse mais vont
parmi les rôles qu'il a refusé jeu
y'a pas pignon puisque henri charrière
le connaissez et quand il ajouta que
jean paul belmondo était quelqu'un de
super 1 et 2 de votre côté comment vous
avez prévu 17 journées cette journée
d'hommage je crois avoir vu une rose
dans votre sac est ce que vous avez à
gérer le programme parce qu'il m'a en
fait dire je suis resté très longtemps
on their évident et puis je ne suis pas
comment c'est là que des benêts
pour les cas plus en fait
je la garderai chez moi pour étiez à la
pause et devant les justes mais
l'important c'est d'être présent
l'important c'est celle et souvenir une
anecdote incroyable je vous montrer la
photo je sais pas si on verra là la
caméra m'a expliqué noé on se quittera
là dessus les dots c'est que pour les
premiers jours que je suis rentré alors
que c'est quand même 37
depuis l'enfance que
j'admirais ni plan l'admirais mais
entend aussi et
le jour où on s'est rencontré en 2000
âge le faire un livre que j'avais gagné
festival / charles vanel dont il
reprenait le rôle
donc 30
plus tard après que
2000 bill 63 et subsistera 2000 2001 et
ont voulu
il m'a dédicacé une photo immense dame
autre chose que j'ai encadré chez moi et
tous et moi je verse cadoule à hilali
bon les gars de faire une photo et on
sait une bnp
indian dans les banlieues
on s'est mis devant la mine témoin j'ai
dit on
il ya et il y a l'autre collègue et ami
daniel moreau d'ailleurs et des amis en
gendarme et
en rigolant devant le photographe a fait
une icône tenir la pause il a divorcé
nord il borde avec un gendarme je suis
bien à 68 ans et 60 ans
l'humour qu'il avait et
moi j'ai pas connaissance des gens
il ya des super merci beaucoup
en tout cas c'est une belle anecdote on
va se quitter là dessus je vous remercie
beaucoup d'adapter voyage vous souhaite
une bonne cérémonie est importante pour
vous j'imagine et je vous souhaite une
très bonne journée merci beaucoup
charlotte voilà pour cette cette
anecdote assez rigolote qui traduit
encore une fois l'humour de ce
personnage qui était jean paul belmondo
de la d'acteurs à mon côté de sa
personnalité qui a été mainte et mainte
fois félicité et surtout à louer depuis
bien il hier avec cet hommage national
aux invalides et aujourd'hui et bien ses
obsèques dans l'intimité à l'église
saint germain des prés merci beaucoup
outils boys auraient pour ses
interventions directes depuis la foule
présente en nombre ce matin pour les
obsèques de jean paul belmondo une
cérémonie intime réservée aux membres de
la famille de jean paul belmondo ainsi
qu'à ses proches parmi les proches
justement on a pu voir arriver certaines
personnalités on a pu voir albert
dupontel jean dujardin pierre-richard
béatrice dalle claude lelouch et puis
évidemment alain delon qui s'est déplacé
et qui a pu rester quelques minutes face
à ce public pour laisser le temps au
public de l'applaudir et eau et aux
photographes et journalistes le prendre
en photo
bertrand guyard est à mes côtés pour
commenter cet événement il était là
également il hier pour commenter
l'hommage national beaucoup d'émotion
bertrand guyard de nouveau ce matin à
l'arrivée de ces familles de ses proches
et puis évidemment à l'entrée du
cercueil de jean-paul belmondo suivi par
ses petits enfants sa fille stella et
son et son fils paul oui c'était
émouvant j'ai à dire que c'était
terrible je vais moi je repense à ces
dernières années puisque on n'a fait que
commenter les disparitions de ses
copains du conservatoire
donc on aura du mal à tous les citer
mais enfin parmi les plus célèbres et
jean pierre marielle
rochefort jean rochefort le dos qui
était pas qui était faisait partie de la
bande mais qui s'étaient connus même
avant ça et
c'est là effectivement on a quand même
l'impression il reste plus que de longs
enfin tout cas de cette génération et
cette génération du grand cinéma
français de l'après-guerre parce qu'au
fond faut comprendre que delon et
belmondo
explose dès les années 1960
l'inde en plein soleil pour et autres
dans à bout de souffle de godard donc 60
ça fait quoi ça fait soixante et un ans
et ça vous fait vous oblige à faire du
calcul mental et c'est ça c'est fait ça
fait ça fait beaucoup plus qu'un demi
siècle donc ça c'est nul ça c'est ça
donc là on alors ce qui est tout à fait
quand même rassurant c'est que y'a vous
on a pas mal de gens qui ont plus de 50
ans
on peut les reconnaître tout à l'heure
une anecdote s'était pas jacques dutronc
mais on avait presque bon c'est un titre
c'est fini ce cas la même façon de
marcher et voilà un jeune lennon il ya
beaucoup mais ya quand même des gens
jeunes 1 c'est ce que je veux pas
répéter ce que j'ai dit hier mais au
fond lorsque pendant le confinement on a
voulu divertir les gens on a pensé
naturellement à de funès évidemment et
on a pensé à belmondo parce que c'était
un un héros souriant c'était le super du
bon le gars qui qui qui flingue mais
toujours avec un mot d'humour alors
c'est vrai qu'il est et qu'il a été
servi et qui l'asservît formidablement
michel audiard qui a trouvé avec lui
après gabin après lino après blier
bernard blier
il a trouvé un nouvel interprète parce
que
belmondo c'est un voyou de bonne famille
en tout cas c'est un titi parisien que
l'accent parisien un accent qui se perd
un peu aujourd'hui
c'était quelqu'un mais c'était en même
temps un voyou de bonne famille je dis
bonne famille parce que ses parents ses
deux parents étaient des artistes son
père paul en était un sculpteur
renommée et sa maman madeleine était une
femme qui était artiste peintre donc
donc il a quand même baignés baigner
baigné dans une atmosphère très très
quand les régions très bienveillante est
très très très nourricière d'un point de
vue artistique d'aider ses plus jeunes
années à la différence d'un de long
qu'il eut effectivement une enfance un
peu un peu plus papa pas complètement
noir n'exagérons pas mais plus difficile
- encore une fois - inspiratrice que
celle de belmondo merci beaucoup
bertrand guyard pour vos éclairages donc
succès les anecdotes sur jean paul
belmondo dont c'est en ce moment même en
l'église de saint-germain-des-prés les
obsèques en présence de sa famille et de
proches dont on a pu voir les arrivées
au fur et à mesure du temps depuis 10h30
heure à laquelle on a pris l'antenne et
ce direct vous voyez sur ces images les
portes de l'église sont désormais fermés
puisque c'est en ce moment même que se
déroule cette cérémonie on devrait
réentendre nous on n'entendra pas mais
en tout cas le public qui est présent et
les invités dans cette église entendront
la musique du professionnel de nouveau à
la demande de jean paul belmondo lui
même
merci encore de nous avoir suivis en
direct depuis hanoï même pour notre
gamme désolé pour la façon dont je
prononce votre non merci pour la
diffusion je suis cela en direct depuis
hanoï nous dit-il merci encore pour
votre témoignage votre émotion
[Musique]
je ne sais plus qui nous disait il ya
quelques minutes sur le chat du figaro
sur youtube il était sur son lieu de
travail où elle était sur son lieu de
travail se retenait de ne pas pleurer en
ce jour fort triste pour les fans et les
amateurs de ce grand acteur qui était
jean paul belmondo je rappelle que nous
avons couvert l'arrivée des invités en
depuis 10h30 ce matin et parmi les
proches du monde du cinéma et du sport
qui se sont présentés aujourd'hui qu'ils
étaient invités on a pu voir brahim
asloum le champion de boxe pierre
richard qui est arrivé au début albert
dupontel jean dujardin qui était
attablée à la terrasse du café des deux
magots
béatrice dalle également été là et puis
thomas dutronc et puis enfin évidemment
alain delon qui est arrivé
et qui n'a pas perdu en grandeur et en
images expressivement impressionnante
malgré la faiblesse de son état physique
merci encore bertrand guyard de nous
avoir permis d'avoir permis ce matin et
quelques éclairages sur les événements
qui se passait depuis l'église de
saint-germain-des-prés merci encore de
nous avoir suivis en direct sur figaro
la vie sur youtube on va se quitter en
vous diffusant quelques unes des plus
belles scènes jouées par jean paul
belmondo dans ces grands films je vous
laisse avec ce petit montage très sympa
monsieur va peut-être nous offrir un
verre vous dépensez pas mesdemoiselles
alors qu'il est d'ailleurs vous devriez
déjà une chez vous je suis vous avez un
parent de la famille un fiancé qui vous
attend
papa langlois tombe de sommeil quant à
mme des mères akio pitbull à nous
mais si mais si allez
un joueur des fusillés mal extrême
orient un manolete tu as linares par le
taureau islero
et celui-là je le bois mon pote gédéon
tombé dans le traquenard blankson à
josélito le plus grande tout ce
mario rio brésil ça ne te dit rien
pourquoi mon livre est pas à moi
à voyenne bonne raison pour qu'on
m'enlève suis la seule qui sache se
trouve la statue de mon père le
professeur catalan est pas mort il le
tient dans les textures drôle
[Applaudissements]
si vous n'aimez pas la mer
si vous n'aimez pas la montagne
si vous n'aimez pas la ville
allez vous faire [ __ ]
bonjour
tu as l'air de dire au revoir des mamans
bonjour moi bonjour comme s'il était un
malade
un bon jour
en
jour
je sens tu préfères les choses pour
point du taux
pas cette femme qui m'a initié à la vie
c'est mon grand père
mon temps mon père était grave timorés
pénétrait du souci de respectabilité
quand lui il était patent quand je
choisis mon tour de chant conservateur
âme et tous les soirs dans mes fans m'a
tout appris
tout
juste avait dit que je serai toujours
derrière toi
[Applaudissements]
pourrais tu as l'air triste
parce que tu me parles avec les mots
comment je te regarde avec tes
sentiments
et trompe pas la conversation
jamais d'idées toujours des sentiments
c'est pas vrai il ya des idées pour lui
sentiments
bon on va essayer d'avoir une
conversation sérieuse que désire
turquier du tout ce que je peux te
donner je peux tout avoir c'est vrai
c'est même plus amusant
si dominique amuse-toi
s'empêche de mourir
[Musique]
en
oh
pour ce qui est de la baloche permettez
moi de vous dire que c'est le pays
intégra
vous permettez mais je vous en prie
pressé par les motos
marie julie je peux dire boucher
t'expliquerai je vais pas vous déranger
à sept heures du soir
bon d'accord d'accord continuer
[Musique]
comme votre peau va bien avec bach
boizel bellecour gaby
héberge auriez-vous pour la nuit un
orphelin sont des fausses
mais bien sûr bonsoir madame ça tu vas
dormir chez michelin il est à l'état
allait débrouille toi
aujourd'hui l'échelle
mais oui tu vas lui faire plaisir tu vas
voir si son grand truc qui compte c'est
pas tout le monde mais c'est comme ça
[Musique]
et ce par quoi
non
je vais pas me taper ce truc là
[Musique]